Robert wool is coming in huggy Rao real
welcome welcome my friend sit down make
yourself at home we were just talking
about your career Jim and I both have
various favorites of things that you've
done in your career that have made us
very excited about this appearance here
on Jim Norton and Sam Roberts welcome
Robert okay it's welcome to you I'm
sorry I'm to three good traffic 911 no
whether they have Road closed off or
just makes you sad to go fast just
backed up I have to go down to the World
Trade Center later oh do you yeah so
what are you doing I'm taping a TV
showed out there and the studios are
down there so Mike I'm kind of like
mixed on it you know it's like a 1/2 I
didn't want to be there right you'd
think they'd give you the day off
right well that's where they're shooting
well that's what the studios are but the
other hand it's like okay you know it's
let's let's take it in that's right yeah
let's take it in right I understand that
Cobb is one of my favorite things ever
you do that makes me so happy it's funny
I judge I've been fortunate and when
people come up to you and they say their
favorite stuff you get a bead of you
know misjudging ly people you know
judging or misjudging on what they like
you know a lot of times it's Batman our
oralist because they were huge and but
so maybe now and that people pick out
low say Bull Durham right but a lot of
does a cult for Hollywood nights the
other thing too one of my favorite
comedies ever right but when somebody
says Cobb man that's that's you know
that's that story special that makes me
really happy I'm Lee Jones had some of
the most fun lines in movie history
Jimmy a week ago when we found out you
were coming in he started talking about
Cobb immediately bored at that movie Bob
it's a sad thing my dark it's door he's
a dark guy was it because he was such a
prick that it bombed or do you through
what's Cobb for ty Cobbs being the
greatest of all time and a [ __ ] as he
got old stumpy get coking go to the cans
by stocking coke and he was just a
racist and a nasty [ __ ] guy and the
first guy they elected into the Hall of
Fame so every time they talk about the
Hall of Fame that's right
the very first guy they put in was Ty
Cobb they probably should have thought I
mean he was always a for
27 average I mean he was doing where's
the 407 I'm wrong you know but although
if he did half of what he did back then
now completely Ty Cobb kicked off
Twitter yeah that none of it would have
flown today way but it was an
interesting movie though because
everyone you know everyone talked about
him as a kid like what a great
ballplayer he was and everyone knew he
was kind of like a hard-ass a curmudgeon
yes but I didn't realize what a [ __ ]
complete nasty racist what about two
years ago some guy wrote a revisionist
history book with the help of a Cobb
family and they've got this guy being
Santa Claus now oh really yeah I mean if
they would say oh there's none this
happened and all the stories came
because of the character I played al
stump wrote badly about him he said it
was all about our stumping he gave this
bit and brunch on oil officially goes
what about the 60 years before I'll
stump even met the guy where everybody
thought he was a prick
yeah I mean that doesn't count suddenly
it's a you know spud its revisionist
history you didn't used to like slide
into bases his cleats on her and and
hurt you both there he way you have to
remembered something else know about
baseball back then this was a tough game
this game was played by tough guys mill
workers you know guys from the south
these were ball you know they were they
they were and they weren't getting paid
and they only getting paid for
production so you got in their way you
know you're [ __ ] with their money so
it was it wasn't a good guy game so much
that's the whole thing right yeah they
let me they worked in the offseason I
mean they they weren't they weren't
making more they made no money back then
Cobb did comedy cop it was a millionaire
when he left baseball really yeah he was
very smart when it came to is that's why
the movies interesting cuz he's such a
complex guy he had some he was played in
Detroit he's from Georgia so he had
stopped on the ground floor in both
coca-cola as he talks about coca-cola
coming out in cans and Fischer body and
General Motors Wow
so he and he used to dine with
presidents I mean this guy but he was a
dark yeah yeah he was a real uh but
would he die he was vomiting blood
cancer yeah and he paid that girl money
to tell her but he was the greatest [ __ ]
she ever had
he was just an awesome [ __ ] awesome
character
and working with Tommy Lee Jones was one
yeah now have you been are you a guy
who's like obsessed with sports and have
kind of because a lot of the projects
that you've done especially the
memorable ones revolve around the sports
world fortunately I am a baseball fan
you have a huge baseball fan and I do
follow some sports
I'm not fanatical but I and but noticed
something last night the jet game that
the Jets you know here's a great tip
from now on for all jet fans we were
listening suffering long suffering the
Jets win every time on Rosh Hashanah so
every five thousand seven hundred and
seventy six years the but I do follow
baseball and also the projects I've been
involved with I've been pretty good I've
been four units a lot of shitty sports
stuff yeah but you know I was Bull
Durham and I was fortunate Arliss I
never saw Bull Durham with constant
right oh it's good yeah good I don't
think I've ever seen it it's a great
pieces on cable I don't never actually
sat down and watch that yeah the thing
about what influenced me Bull Durham
when I did Arliss is that it's about
characters it's not about the big game
most sports movies suck because they're
about the big game this isn't it's about
characters in the world of the minor
leagues and their hopes and dreams
and their characters are people and
that's what I did in Donora was pretty
much as it wasn't about sports it was
about characters in the world of sports
more when it's about the big game you
know what's gonna happen you wanna
[ __ ] know are they're gonna win
there's gonna be the swell of the music
it's gonna be the touchdown or whatever
it's gonna be because we're told they're
told is Ron Schott let's say they're
always told from this point of view of
the fan right and the fan only cares
about one thing whether the team wins or
loses right that's it
Ron Shelton was a ball player he said I
don't know what the fans thinking I know
what the guy at second base is thinking
he's thinking I'm trying to keep my job
right right you know that's that's a
different thing and it's a lot more
interesting and say that's the
perspective that you don't like all
everybody who goes to watch a movie can
understand the fan perspective but when
when it's told from a player perspective
that's when you're learning like oh
that's what this world is yes you know
yes or the guy who sells the peanuts
right or the guy who's the ticket tailor
right good seller or the general
managers job or you know when you learn
about them it's interesting it's more
telling when you're into that world
right I love that that's why I love
stuff when you're going into this other
world yeah
yeah you did you do are you doing
stand-up or no you know I don't do it
much it I haven't done it a little while
and I did get up on stage a couple of
times in the last year I was hosting
some stuff and I actually enjoyed it
why did you use to not that's a great
question
it wasn't what I set out to do I use it
as a vehicle and I always thought am i
any good at this even though I'm doing
really well and there were times when I
was doing stand-up early on where I
would be an arrhythmia and I said boy
this is like jazz almost you know it was
really good but I didn't for a couple
things number one I didn't like working
clubs and dealing with drunks anymore
I just got burned out yeah and you know
you're at a certain age - are you going
to relate to the audience then you
realize dummy the audience grows up -
sometimes except where it depends on the
venue when did I did enjoy it when I did
it recently I have to say I did enjoy it
well bombing does stink and chase a lot
of people out I mean it's it's an awful
feeling yeah yeah army I'll tell you
story about bombing
I was in Dallas years ago best paying
gig I've ever had to this day I was at a
corporate corporate gig for this cotton
ball and I was the entertainment and
when I knew I was in trouble when they
told me oh cuz you're doing it for the
college teams it was Texas and LSU I
think that year and you're doing it for
them and their families now keep in mind
who these players are they're football
players from down south and their
families all dressed and you know they
come from you know the Louisiana and
everywhere and they're all the parents
are all and they're sunday-go-to-meeting
best and this is not my crap I knew I
was in trouble they said Leno bomb last
year you know how have you heard that
yeah well to say that I did badly is
ugly I did worse in Dallas than Kennedy
when did you realize at one point up
when you're up there you go oh my god
this is gonna be really bad about 30
seconds you know yeah when opening line
gets next to nothing you know I I did
one of those it was nothing like that it
was for the the Ohio State Buckeyes and
the Miami Hurricanes both teams together
it was at the Meadowlands and it was
just a team dinners or something I think
I paid 300 bucks this is many years ago
I did not it was not a big corporate and
it was okay but I
remember not being as much fun as I
thought it's like their families weren't
there
if the family Sarah was in worse because
then they're watching the players are
watching with her families are laughing
in it it's right Plus this this is not
my crowd this was how much time did you
have to do that's all I want to do about
40 minutes it felt like for 40 minutes
and I felt like four and you do the
whole party you did right for the money
yeah exactly
and you knew 30 seconds in oh this is
gonna be tough and you're like I got 40
minutes of those stories that would
space with you that would lose another
one was at the goat Garden State Arts
Center you I don't know what it's called
now but he's be the Garden State Art
Center in New Jersey on Holmdel New
Jersey was you know big outdoor arena
and I was opening from Miss Diana Ross
and which was a you know ordinarily good
gig but had you open for her before
no no but here's what happened is that
show starts at 8 o'clock now most time
with show starts at 8 o'clock what
time's a start 8:15 this is New Jersey
and the unions are there right and I
mean as soon as that second hand hit 8
o'clock you're on and it's summer and
it's bright outside half the crowd
hasn't arrived it I don't think there's
a hundred people and it's in this two
thousand and it's there all over the
place and I'm talking and I'm doing my
and there's nobody paying attention I
mean it's just like doing a warm-up back
for a crowd that hasn't arrived yet yeah
and after about 12 minutes I said okay
time got through my Tyrael okay okay
good night the next day the next day I
was prepared for it so I went out there
with a totally different mindset and
just rammed through it and it was much
better but you know in this it's tough
to me comedy during the day but you know
what Freddy music is hard anyway when
you do that corporate gig and you just
just just eat a dick for 40 minutes when
you get offstage does whoever's booking
it or does the corporate person do they
come to you and be like what the hell
was what am I paying you for
before I went onstage I'm not there
about 15 people in the wings and we're
joking and everything when I got off
stage there wasn't a person
they had all left there was I'm looking
around and they wanted my swag back yes
yes they wanted how did they answer a
packet they did they asked for it back
they did you say can we get a advance
they wouldn't paid me that's great
they asked for the swag man yeah did you
get back to him no no you kept in know
[Laughter]
that awkward silence would you walk off
they don't know to say to you I mean the
people offstage it was like you know I
was like in a ghost town I love that
comic mentality though when they're like
we want the swag back and you're like no
cuz what happened to me that's your
fault and your audience's fault okay I
know what I'm doing but for whatever
reason you know I said they paid me a
lot of money it's a job I did the
professional job but man was this one
our listeners on yeah that's suck see
you shine and you got a reputation
Garland's a huge show thanks a lot oh
yeah it's going back on Friday yeah I'm
excited better I feel like Arliss is
like the one show that's not on HBO GO
we were always a stepchild over there so
because and I wasn't already for the
intimacy of some of the critics they
made that money after who don't like
sports at all
and we were just because they were at
that time they were having sex in the
city and Six Feet Under
we were before them 96 to 2000 - right
what's a 96 - right so feel like after
Larry Sanders you were one of the first
right that was right up here Tommy
exactly and we were very polarizing but
now it's grown and there's a lot of
revisionist thinking about it and we're
going back on the air Friday all 80
original uncut episodes then you know
that's these are the real deals are on
HBO go and HBO on and the on-demand and
it's great to revisit them because I had
forgotten about like I didn't forget
about him but I realized no we weren't
after topics that I was allowed to do
because HBO wasn't in cahoots with any
of the major sports leagues so I could
say whatever I loved I could do any
story I wanted so I mean we went after
stuff like steroid abuse domestic abuse
gay ballplayers Alzheimers
all kind I'm not being on a network
means that there's no sports on HBO so
they don't have to sit there and be like
hey that's our big right that's that's
the Big Dawg that's the cash cow we
gotta we gotta make them have yeah
exactly you didn't have to and plus I
had the four too because then I had HBO
boxing and HBO Sports helping me if I
had to go do something with real sports
with Bryant Gumbel if I had to go to a
boxing match you know hey I got to be
able to do all that so and be able to
tell any story I want it anyway I think
that a lot of the critical stuff for our
list too was people not knowing how to
take television on HBO right HBO had
been the movie channel for so long
Sanders about but Sanders was a world
they knew exactly see they didn't know
sports and a lot and I was not ready for
this a lot of critics snarky snarky
critics just you know hate sports
yeah they hate the athletes they hate
sports they didn't play sports they
didn't like jocks didn't like so they
didn't they would watch a half an
episode and then hit make up their mind
for the next seven years they don't like
anything around sports either know a lot
exactly and so I'm the best good one of
the you know that but at the same time
the New York Times was great to us
mhm the you know Neil Simon stops me on
the street one day the late great Neil
Simon and those walk it and here comes
no silently and he goes you're doing
great work now
what's that was a writer write David
Halberstam Milch came up to me I don't
know if you realize this is before he
did Deadwood and he said I know if he
realized it but you're changing stuff up
there and so that would make me feel
just great and then Fran Lebowitz you
know friendly woods she's I was at the
Tribeca Film Festival one time she's
changed Murphy she comes with me goes I
hate sports but I love your show you
know so that made you feel okay I'm
doing something here you know the
critics would get to you like you're
you're you you end up reading a lot of
that stuff well I was executive producer
and I had a fight for the show all the
time so I had to find the good one so I
could use it as a do that you gotta take
the bad the bad ordinarily you know
snorky snarky rank you know what didn't
they like about do they say what they
watch they just like sports they didn't
think was funny they go what is this
show oh you know he should take shots
all the time they didn't watch was a 30
rock that's what is it it's a drama is
it it's a comedy it
funny is it serious cuz I would blend
genres in the same episode I never some
of it being funny like this was
something new I it's like I didn't get
it but it was fine we've speeded 7 years
80 episodes a story
I'm Tommy Lasorda I used to be on the
show every now and then cuz we had 200
athletes on the show and one time we met
the Dodger Stadium and I'm sitting with
Tommy and Tommy in the owners box and
Tommy says Robert how long do I shall
run I go we did seven a season we did 80
episodes he goes I'll tell you what's
wrong with your show he says it's the
language did you have to use that kind
of language I said Tommy we're on HBO he
goes I don't give a [ __ ] no idea what he
said and the entire box just broke up
laughing it's like that's where baseball
players talk anyway they curse right
yeah well we everybody that was why we
David Wells love to come on the show cuz
he could curse him but we have everybody
I we had just about everybody on the
show was that a throw for you as a
baseball fan to work with these guys in
or work with them is a different story
because you know they were window
dressing to me
they were texture uh-huh did stories
weren't about that right they were there
to add color and to you know make it
realistic in a way to have a real bass
player yeah sure to me was like watching
Jack Benny and we always had to say we
had a Jack Benny each athlete because
without their costumes or their uniforms
on well people didn't know who they are
right so we'd you know Jack Benny would
say look everybody it's Bobby Darin so
he would say hey there's Jerry there's
Roy Jones jr. or hey how's it going you
know so I had to do all that stuff
but they were great because they were
there for cameos you don't ask him to
carry plot you cannot be stupid so you
ask you don't ask him to do something
they could not do but what they were
good at most good athletes are coachable
and so if you give them reps or or takes
they got better on every take now do you
watch the rock show he doesn't show by
ballers yeah I saw one episode mm-hmm
that's more of a straight comedy ballers
that's like an infusion of of I guess
Arliss meets Entourage a little bit
which is funny because Mark Wahlberg
came up to me and and Markinson said you
know the entourage would not have
happened without Arliss we used our
Lass's ar-ar-ar give template that's it
so did you
do you own the show like is that the
reason why we never on no sure I would
have horde it out no fight on the show
would be like no it was HBO it was like
I just kept it off it was locked in at
fault really yeah they kept it off for
awhile
wonder why did that drive you a little
bit nuts as a creator yes uh but I think
it's gonna work for the better now I
think because it hasn't been on so long
and the fact that when you look back and
we see all the athletes on the show and
believe me it's a time capsule when you
see everything we get Kobe Bryant on
when he just came out of high school and
signed his contract and it was funny cuz
he just signed a 45 million dollar
contract and we're doing his scene with
him I see this woman standing over there
in the corner go who's that woman and
the director says uh that's the social
worker what he means social worker he
goes well he's underage he's gotta have
a social he just signed a 45 minutes I
mean Kobe Bryant on what he did that we
had Roy Jo not Floyd Mayweather away he
just come out of the Olympics and he was
pretty boy floyd mayweather Wow his
original name Pretty Boy Floyd Floyd
before was money Mayweather he's young
yeah he was like we had everybody the
only ones we didn't have on this show
were Martina Navratilova and Ali you
know and that was about it turned Ollie
down yeah but that was who was the best
actor I totally yeah best athlete as an
actor well let's take to all the
commentators out of the mix yeah Costas
and yeah there there dear performers
Lincoln Kennedy
believe it or not it was an offensive
lineman for many years I think with
Seattle was a drama minor we find out in
it there so I could actually actually
got him to carry some plot so he was
good yeah cuz he was about us his about
his mother who was being buried
somewhere and I sent them a copy of des
memory it's a mad mad mad mad world sure
remember dick Shawn mama I'm coming to
see your mama you know the whole thing
so I had him watch it and he did it and
Mama
we're comin you know so he was really
good Reggie Miller really good Clemmons
good bombs good who had a hard time yeah
what what athlete got onto the set and
you're like oh my god the athletes were
okay because of if they weren't in their
arena do you know they were
or arena so they really wanted to make
you know I really want to do well I had
trouble with one person but he wasn't an
athlete who is he Bruce Hornsby wow
that's just the way it is right yeah the
singer oh man why he pulled an ego trip
really the whole day it was different he
was difficult Barry was the only on one
episode
thank God yeah do you sit there and
you're like it's too late to get another
singer well it wasn't a singer what
happened was it was an episode where it
was about arles had always wanted to get
been in a garage band he played the
piano and he wanted always to get a gold
record so he puts together all his
athletes to make one of these we are the
world charity called the jockstrap
and what happens during the episode is
his assistant Kirby brings in Bruce
Hornsby and our bum who bumps all of us
out of playing piano well horse means
manager called before the year and said
Bruce a big fan of the show we'd like to
do it I'm thinking what would what am I
gonna have to Bruce Hornsby but then
when this came up
he came on did it and then after the
first rehearsal he says listen my fans
know I don't do this I'm gonna leave I
go what do you mean gonna leave now I
wouldn't have minded it so much accepted
we shot single cameras so he shot six
days so we shoot out of order and the
first five days were already in the can
when we keep talking about Bruce Hornsby
so I can't replace oh yeah he said it
yeah all right we're in the kid so I had
a tap dance all day long and him saying
well my fans know I don't do these kind
of charity things and my fans know I
don't do this thing and we got through
it when I've relayed the story to Max
Weinberger the E Street Band one day he
said well why didn't you just call the
fan and ask him if it was ok you don't
know how I'm doing that in the back of
my mind but I can't do it because you've
had too much [ __ ] tap dance yeah Wow
who else didn't show up who Troy Aikman
I'm the day of the shoot said I don't
feel like doing it and we got a crew
waiting and the other one was Raul
Mondesi who said I was with Robert last
night
yeah so I'm five hours or five hours
would like 7 o'clock at night yeah I
said I'll see you tomorrow he never
showed up but Robbie just didn't feel
like doing it yeah that's an [ __ ] bit
of a dick
yeah with the quarter he was oh no he
was uh he was still quite back at the
time that's why he's quite back to
Cowboys so he can do whatever he wants
being a dick because he can be that
power yeah
what happened after Arliss you did the
one-man show write the history stuff
yeah yeah I did I came up with this idea
to talk to Chris what I think I think I
can do a history lecture which can be
funny in front of colleges and we did
two shows assume the position and there
was history monologues that we did you
ever see them and I did they were
interesting yeah yeah I did it NYU with
lots of real students and there's
actually in a lecture hall yeah it was
in the gotcha yeah and they were really
well-received in fact probably the best
most well-received thing I've ever done
and I stayed away from sports yeah and
that went really well we were going to
do another one and then the money backed
out it wasn't on HBO the HBO turnover
came and then Chris left you mean yeah
yeah and then then we were going to do
then I was gonna do it again because I
became partners with Glenn Frey and we
became very good friends because funny
because Glenn was on the week after
Hornsby and everybody said you sure you
want another rock star after this and I
said I've met Glenn I go I know Glenn a
little bit and then we became really
close friends and in fact I was writing
with Glenn the we were doing a musical
version of Hotel California and then he
gets sick and it came out of nowhere but
a musical version of Hotel California
yeah we did it we actually go the moon
like a music I was already music yes we
were doing a musical about that okay
Hotel California's and and he got six
very subtly how long until he died from
the time he announced he was sick well
he goes not much what happened was we
were doing a workshop at the University
of Michigan's great great musical
theater department and we had in fact we
actually did it an madonna's daughter at
the time was my Donna's daughter played
the witchy woman and it was it was
terrific but Glenn got sick just before
we way he's like late I'd say August
August and then he was in the hospital
for tests for stomach and he didn't get
out of there for a while and I said
what's going on he goes and they don't
know what I got he goes I'll tell you
one thing when I get out of here not
that I didn't live good to begin with
when I get out of here I'm really living
good because Robert it could be over in
an instant in an instant I hear that
every day of my life
and then he was going to come and then
he flew to New York and then part of
what happens far as from what I've
learned is Glenn
had rheumatoid arthritis for years so to
do that you take anti immune drugs no
that's that stuff you see on TV with all
the side effects we make fun of side
effects are real mm-hmm and they can be
real very real and when he got the
colitis
they gave him more drugs more anti
immune and that everything crashed and
his lungs he had to be rushed to the
hospital and he was on a vent on they
put him in a medically induced coma and
then he caught pneumonia and when you
got pneumonia and you have no immune
system it's not yep yeah yeah that's why
I you know with people back in the day
when everybody would dying of AIDS they
would never say AIDS because the
technical things they died of pneumonia
because they had no immune system and so
that's so he went fast yeah it was it
was weird and I can tell you and became
one of my quote if not my closest friend
one of them and I miss him we laughed so
much I mean we we laughed a lot I mean
Don Henley get along at the end uh
getting along because I was traveling
with the band they yes yes the band
there wasn't you know the band it was a
good job you know everybody knew that
and boy they were good is the winner
some bands can't get it together like
yeah I can ABBA they offered so much
money to and they just won't do it
yeah for the longest time Guns and Roses
was like that they finally got back
together and said the greatest thing
yeah yeah they were amazing life yeah
absolutely incredible did you ever did
you were you pitching more series series
after this or or was it like yeah I did
I kind of want to get away no no I did a
lot you know I just like I wrote a play
that was on at the Queens Theatre I did
a lot of stuff but nobody saw it or it
didn't get made it or he was in
development hell for a very long time so
that's you know the great thing about
when I used to write the Oscars with
Billy Crystal is right you knew your
work was gonna be seen right you know
how much of our work that never is seen
is that tough when you get arles made do
you right after our list start feeling
like okay well the next thing I write is
gonna get made too and when it doesn't
you're like what I what's happening or
no no no I I think every project is
pretty much just or from scratch I
gotcha
you know unless you are superstars like
that yeah yeah there's no guarantee yeah
my first introduction to you was Batman
uh-huh was that 30 years next year
that's amazing yeah I stand by the way
it still holds up way more than any
other like none of those old Christopher
Reeve Superman movies hold up to me
there was a prior one dose well yeah
that was it was that was good for the
because of James yeah whatever but to me
the Tim Burton Batman movie none of the
other sequels hell even the Batman
Returns for me doesn't really it's like
but but that first one you Keaton
Nicholson Tim Burton directing it it's
like you can watch that today and it
still completely holds up with wit as
good as any Batman movie for me what's
thank you for saying that interesting to
me with that first series of that Batman
you know that that those Batman's you
know in the 80's 90's it's funny because
to me every hour of that series gets
progressively worse the first hour the
first Batman is incredible the second
hour pretty damn good yeah the next one
not as good the next one geez and by the
time you got the nipples on Robin is
this yeah did you watch those shoot
shoot Joe Schumacher movie is going like
this is related to the thing that I did
yeah yeah and I said boy this is a piece
of [ __ ] why aren't I in it's a piece of
[ __ ] and they wanted to put you in it
yeah do you feel that when you win when
Batman Returns comes out and even though
it's like nobody's it Michael Keaton's
in it but you know Vicky vales not
everybody's gone do you still go like
well there's there's still room for me
in this oh no I was gonna put me right
there I know I totally expect it to be
in the sequel and then I got too cold
you know but a couple months before
shooting that my character wasn't in the
movie do you feel hurt like because you
probably you know develop some level of
familiarity with Tim Burton and then you
find out hurt disappointed more not do
you not personally oh no no no you can't
take anything personally unless unless
you have a personal sure thing go they
just didn't find a reason for the
character right exactly I'm sure cuz of
course was interesting in the original
script in the original Batman the first
one I died NOx died and then they kept
them alive because they liked them so
much okay so so this really caught me
off which gave you false hope which they
should have just killed it kind of
today yet yeah on some level wish that
they've killed you so it's like there's
a finality to that character or you
don't care that much at this stage
doesn't man oh except I got only because
I could've got to them to do a death
scene right yeah that would have been
cool but that's that's the bet I was
when they said you suppose keeping you
alive it was like all cool man the next
one Batman the annuity yeah franchise
yeah you see you see a bunch of games
were you surprised that uh that Michael
Keaton was the pake because people a lot
of times forget that Michael Keaton is
this famous comic editor people don't
realize now cuz it's a different
generation right how controversial that
pic was was a hugely because everybody
knew him from either Beetlejuice or mr.
mom right and a you know what originally
they once I think the Bill Murray or
they went to a to some comic and they
they were gonna go and Tim was against
it Tim Tim was against Michael Keaton no
Tim Tim was Michael King because of
breed of juice gotcha
and and I knew Michael from the clubs I
knew he was an actor and also I don't
know if anybody ever so if you ever go
back watch a movie called clean and
sober I've seen that how good is Michael
Keaton in that movie I didn't love the
movie and I liked him and right he was
really good yeah meets about drug addict
and I said he can do this thing and but
people don't realize the backlash of
Michael Keaton as Batman now we laugh at
that and can't comprehend well you hit
it on the head most people don't
remember that but you knew when you were
shooting scenes with him then it's like
yeah this is clearly working yes
you know Michael might remember you got
Jack and you had Michael and you know
jack is how much fun of me I was at the
party when a girl came up to Jack and
said you wanted to dance and Jacqueline
wrong verb so I mean and no raconteur is
better than Jack Nicholson he'll tell
stories you know so I'm at a party years
of going here when London and I'm
coconut Princess Margaret I did do coke
with the best of them didn't it oh sure
people do take a lot for granted in that
movie number one the Jack Nicholson is
just in it cuz that's another one that
you're like holy [ __ ] Jack Nicholson is
gonna play the Joker and just the
concept of a superhero movie being this
dark and being this sort of serious
about it that didn't happen you have to
remember that the time Batman it's the
most expensive movie ever made
Wow and we shot it in London at Pinewood
Studios which is the James Bond Studios
enormous and to walk in there to walk
onto the set the first time to see
Gotham City and you saw it there it was
like oh my god this is cool man you know
Tim Burton is an artist he mean this
guy's an artist and it was so much fun
and it was just great there was no there
was nothing spared do you've anything to
Jack just one very briefly scene when we
pass each other but we would talk every
day he give me rides in his car and
great stories and just hearing all the
stuff and he taught me how to smuggle
weed into London I tell every people I
did some stupid things in my life and I
smuggled weed into one like I'm gonna
tell you the name of the actor but what
he said to me cuz I don't wanna get in
trouble what he said to me was what you
do is your mail a fan letter to yourself
saying you don't know me but here's a
little something to keep you going that
way if they catch you go I don't know
who that is brilliant and it sounded
just like Jack a little something for
you as a fan what is smart although if
you're Jack you just guess I'm gonna get
it for you I will say there is one scene
exactly there is one scene in the film
that you're not in the scene there's
there's one scene in the film and I've
talked about it before that maybe well I
didn't watch things I wasn't in cringes
it's what did you think the first time
you saw the scene of Michael Keaton
asking if if the villain wanted to get
nuts come on let's get nuts I don't
remember it okay how can you not
remember it Troy pulling up pulling up
video because I want to know just say
yeah Batman let's get nuts because it is
it is it is the weirdest the weirdest
scene it might be there you go yeah
there's a 12 second version there it is
okay that's a little I mean it comes out
of nowhere you know it's not exactly as
the the Bruce Wayne that takes place in
the rest of the movie
you don't remember so you know I
remember the scene I block it out
because I'm trying to remember it
because I don't didn't remember that
there was a scene with Bruce Wayne and
the Joker right well that's what he
wasn't in costume I don't remember that
because the Joker is trying to get Vicki
Vale and Vicki Vale is with Bruce Wayne
and the Joker I don't think at that
point yet realizes that Bruce Wayne is
Batman but he's kind of showing his hand
a little bit when he starts breaking
things and saying let's get nuts I'll
tell you how great was Jack's cast it
was the joke for not amazing phenomenal
you know didn't see a thing about the
recent versions of The Dark Knight is I
know they're good movies and everything
but I didn't dig him as much and this is
probably the thing about age and
generational but the Batman we had was
dark but it was fun it was fun still
yeah these recent Batman's to me are not
you like the one that still had more of
a comic book vibe well it was fun I did
not like the TV series at all cuz I was
too campy yeah me but it was fun there
was a twinkle in Jack's eye there was
fun you know it's like it was you know
Prince songs in the hole like you could
still see it was based in like a comic
book cartoon world that's the bait
that's the foundation and the colors and
everything in the sit beside you didn't
meet Prince did you know in a Tim didn't
want Prince songs in the movie if he was
against that whole really I was a studio
thing that was totally the back Tim on
that he had just done Purple Rain so
they were back in this movie do you know
it'd be like it I think we have two
Beatles catalog you know but Prince but
now that they're in the movie I I kind
of say okay it were yeah and Jim you
like that Dan so I really don't care for
that at all no no you did like that song
I don't care for that that did you know
what's interesting on the first day is
shooting again coming up on 30 years of
Batman the first day of shooting worked
like so we're in London and I'm a
baseball fan and I didn't know that I
read the papers in the morning that the
Dodge Dodgers beat the Oakland A's in
the bottom of the ninth on a home run I
said okay it's cool so I had no idea but
the Kirk Gibson home run it was like I
give a hell
with one leg and hit the ball on the
part so I didn't know anything except
the Dodgers one so I corresponds you
know where where you were at that time
kind of thing so the Batman experience
was just great you know it's weird that
you do a Jack Nicholson so well because
actually my co-host Jim he does a joke I
do
impression that if you shut your eyes
it's like you're back in Gotham City
ready yeah Travis what are you doing
I'll get you Batman
that's it why do you turn around because
you wanted to pretend I see the face I
just have to get myself instead he nails
it every time